despite the surge of coronavirus cases
in several states president Trump wants
the schools to reopen on time yesterday
he tweeted this schools must open in the
fall
today mr. Trump is hosting an event to
discuss reopening with K through 12 and
higher education professionals students
and their parents this comes as
universities try to figure out what to
do make Oliver's near Princeton's campus
that's in New Jersey of course so Meg
good morning to you what are the plans
for that school gaol good morning
students will be allowed back on campus
this fall for one semester of the
academic year freshmen and juniors and
the fall seniors and sophomores in the
spring but administrators say most of
the classes will remain online across
the country the nearly 20 million
students returning to college this fall
can expect a very different experience
Alonzo Hart a rising junior at Princeton
plans to take his college classes nearly
seven thousand miles from campus after
traveling to South Korea for an
internship
earlier this year he's decided to stay I
don't know if it would be the best idea
to go back and you know completely
expose myself in that environment if
people not if not everyone's gonna take
it seriously including college students
Princeton like many other schools will
require everyone on campus to wear face
coverings indoors at all times except
when students are in their assigned
rooms have to social distance and
isolate everyone in their own room it's
just not really appealing to me it
doesn't really feel like the true
college experience incoming Harvard
freshman Yasmine Bezos was excited of
the university's announcement Monday
that it will welcome 40% of undergrads
to campus including all freshman
students will be tested every three days
start somewhat of a normal experience
you feel like you're taking a health
risk by going back definitely not
especially considering my age if I was
some faculty parents and health experts
have expressed concerns about the virus
spreading quickly among social college
students last week more than 100
students living in fraternity houses
near the University of Washington
reported testing positive for kovat 19
The Chronicle of Higher Education looked
at the campus reopening plans at more
than a thousand schools 60% plan to
return to an in-person semester 9% will
continue all remote learning in 24% will
offer a mix with the others still
deciding schools also have to consider
that students may not want to pay full
tuition to learn online students faculty
staff administrators former US Secretary
of Education Arne Duncan says he
understands students frustrations in
hopes they will see the big picture now
if there's a campus outbreak CDC
officials advise shutting down buildings
to disinfect and working with local
health officials to trace contact if the
community spread is substantial they
advise making sure that those in-person
classes are suspended for a much longer
period of time Tony tough choices there
may be there's a big change coming this
fall semester for international students
who are taking classes here in the US
what do we know about that
that's right immigration and customs
enforcement says that international
students with visas under the student
and exchange program cannot take a full
course of online classes which means
they either have to transfer to a school
with in-person classes or leave the
country we talked with one Pakistani
student who has lived in the US for 11
years and he told us that leaves him in
no-man's land the most recent numbers
estimate that more than 1.5 million
students rely on those visas Tony yeah
Arne Duncan says it right we're talking
about one fall here of course if it's
one of the four Falls you have for your
college education you're going to feel
it
make thank you very much